well we are going to have a very
interesting Senate race for the
Democratic Primary in California in
2024. last week we talked on the bonus
show about congresswoman Katie Porter
announcing that she's running for Dianne
Feinstein's senate seat Dianne Feinstein
has been in the senate about 30 years
she has not yet actually said she is not
running in 2024 but Katie Porter has
decided she is going to run the latest
news is that Adam Schiff is joining that
very same race NBC news reporting Adam
Schiff running for Senate in California
joining a crowded 2024 primary so two
members of Congress now at minimum are
going to be fighting against each other
uh actually three because of Barbara Lee
um Adam Schiff announced Thursday he's
running for Senate joining what is
expected to be a crowded race Feinstein
has not announced her plans but already
three prominent California Democrats
have set their sights on replacing her
Schiff and Congress Representatives
Katie Porter and Barbara Lee
Schiff says Democrats need a fighter in
the Senate who's been at the center of
the struggle for our democracy and our
economy he looks forward to campaigning
hard meeting Californians where they are
and listening to what they want from
their next Senator you know I got a few
emails from many of you fine folks
saying David isn't this uh isn't this
dangerous isn't this potentially going
to lose a senate seat for Democrats in
California I don't think that there's
any risk of that I really don't I think
a hard-fought primary
um is fine and should be welcomed in
most cases and California is very blue
and in almost
for sure terms we can say that the
winner of that Democratic primary will
be the next senator from California for
me the more interesting question is are
these folks who are going to be running
against Dianne Feinstein and I think
there's two Dynamics at play that are
going on now many of you this this is
not the type of thing we make fun of
there is a reality that there have been
real concerns cognitively about Dianne
Feinstein for a couple of years reports
that
um she will meet people regularly in her
course of being a senator and not
remember that she's met them before or
multiple times we've even seen very kind
of tough to watch public situations
where Feinstein will read a question to
a witness during testimony during a
hearing and then immediately read the
exact same question a second time with
no recognition that she's already asked
that question they're real questions
she's getting uh to to uh you're just
getting up there in age and we want to
be sensitive to all these things part of
this may be an effort to push her out by
saying look there's so many people
running there's not even really a
guarantee you would win this is a good
time to maybe maybe move on the other
speculation about why we are seeing so
much early announcement for this seat is
that some of these folks Katie Porter
Barbara Lee Adam Schiff they may hope
that by announcing early they will keep
others from entering the race by showing
look I'm a strong candidate I'm well
known I have a good shot at this thing
don't even bother getting involved and I
don't know whether anyone has been
dissuaded so far from entering that race
because of the early announcements but
it is going to be a very interesting
race it's not going to be a race that
will be material in terms of the balance
uh if Dianne Feinstein doesn't run
she's going to be replaced by by one of
these Democrats because of California's
voting demographics and so in that sense
it won't be interesting to the balance
but it will be an interesting race to
see the direction that Californians are
are leaning I don't have a strong
opinion about these three right now
nor do I vote in California so I am not
inclined to come out right now and say
Here's the one of these three that
should definitely be supported I'm
actually interested in interested in
seeing how the campaign rolls on
um George Santos is now admitting to
another possible crime and this one
requires a bit of an explanation
Business Insider reports George Santos
hints that the five hundred thousand
dollar personal loan to his own campaign
wasn't his own money
now that raises questions as to whether
that violated campaign Finance law he
may be effectively admitting to a crime
George Santos made significant by the
way this is George Anthony Katara De
volder Santos that's the person we're
talking about George Santos made
significant revisions to campaign
finances on Tuesday per The Daily Beast
the amended filings revealed that a five
hundred thousand dollar personal loan to
his 2022 campaign wasn't personally
funded experts say the amended filings
add to the mystery of Santos's
questionable Financial disclosures so
the initial filing showed a box for
personal funds of the candidate for that
big loan the amended filing did not
check that it also doesn't mention the
source of the funds if there was a
guarantor uh because there's very little
information provided another revised
filing disclosed that a separate hundred
and twenty five thousand dollar loan
from Santos in October to his campaign
is no longer listed as coming from his
personal fund so this is over six
hundred thousand dollars that he
previously said was my own money and now
it appears as though it is not unless of
course this is just an error maybe the
new filing is the erroneous one with
George Santos it's always hard to know
was he lying then is he lying now what's
going on so a couple different things
here first of all are we aware of
anything about his campaign that isn't
fraudulent I guess it seems that he
really is a gay man Even though even
that was sort of questioned because he
was married to a woman as recently as
three years ago but he says he was
openly gay for a decade and I I want to
be sensitive to that because there are
all sorts of different reasons why
someone who is gay might not be living
publicly as a gay person because of
stigma social pressure family whatever
the confusion is he says he was living
publicly as a gay man for a decade so
it's all very confusing but it at least
appears that he really is a gay man and
he has not lied about that but beyond
that this is one of the most dishonest
people in every sense volleyball star
who ended up needing to have two knee
Replacements because of the wear and
tear on his knees where he worked he was
Jewish I can't even give you the entire
full list there are some Rumblings and
I mean we've heard this so many times
with Trump right this is it this is the
end of trump and then it never is there
are Rumblings that if indeed it turns
out that this was an illegal campaign
contribution from someone else because
remember there are different rules about
you loaning your own campaign money
versus accepting contributions this
large from other people which is not
allowed so there could be a crime here
there are Rumblings that if it is
determined that indeed he did receive an
illegal contribution in this way that
this could finally be the last straw
this guy seems to have a similar
resilience as Donald Trump so I'm going
to withhold judgment for the time being
the conspiracies about the Joe Biden and
Mike Pence classified document
situations are growing Marjorie Taylor
green is now suggesting that Joe Biden
was set up with the documents by
democrats because Democrats don't want
Biden to run again let's start with this
clip then I'll remind you of the one
from two days ago where Tucker had his
own conspiracy theory about this think
of this criticism from Democrats of Mr
Biden and his handling of classified
documents well they're they're right to
say those things but also makes me
wonder something else that that other
people have been wondering or are we
seeing a set up for them to try to get
Joe Biden not to run for president and
perhaps Make Way for someone else to run
for president in 2024. I think those are
those are interesting things to think
about but I'm glad to see you know
Democrat senators and different
Democrats uh just clay blaming what is
absolutely true how Reckless and
irresponsible it shows that he's not fit
for office I'll say it again impeach Joe
Biden and now we just have more reasons
to do so yeah so of course very very
quiet is Marjorie Taylor green on the
Mike Pence thing you know sometimes when
there's a conspiracy theory you can
plausibly come up with some kind of
motive but no further Evidence I don't
even think the motive makes sense here
and what I mean by that is maybe I'm
naive there are many Fair criticisms of
Joe Biden I don't think Joe Biden would
be irrational if
The Establishment
insiders advisors trusted people came to
him and said listen you shouldn't run
for re-election and here's why I think
if that was actually presented to Joe
Biden because top Democrats believed it
to be true I really do believe Joe Biden
would listen I don't think you would
need to try to push him out of running
for re-election by creating a fake
Scandal by planting documents I just
don't see any reason why you would need
to do that now one of the other
important things to consider is
is this a confession for Marjorie Taylor
green because oftentimes allegations
from Republicans about things Democrats
supposedly did are actually confessions
of things they they did we found that
out very quickly in the 2020 election so
maybe it did happen but it's actually
Republicans who did it I don't know but
the very same people Furious about what
happened with Biden seem to be silent
about what happened with Mike Pence now
as a reminder this is not the only
conspiracy theory regarding classified
documents two days ago I played this
clip from you for you where Tucker
Carlson had the idea that the Joe the um
it's hard to keep up now the Mike Pence
documents were uh set up to make Trump
look bad and take attention away from
Joe Biden he said that a few times then
just days ago Mike Pence sent his
personal attorney to search his family's
home in Carmel Indiana for classified
documents right
now if Mike Pence didn't think he had
classified documents why would he send
his lawyer to go look for classified
documents we can't say for certain but
it's entirely possible in fact it's
likely that Mike Pence was asked to do
this by federal prosecutors who are
trying to build a case against his old
boss Donald Trump now the point would be
to show that not every federal official
walks off with State Secrets Donald
Trump was uniquely evil in that regard
as in so many others see Mike Pence
didn't do it
so if that was the plan and we suspect
that it was it backfired spectacularly
because Mike Pence's lawyer if this is
actually what happened and we have no
evidence for it it is completely
irresponsible conjecture that I just
came up with five minutes ago and they
put it on my teleprompter for me but
let's assume that it's true just for the
sake of arguably discovered classified
documents he immediately loaded these
documents into his car and drove them
back to Washington to hand them over to
authorities yeah one of the things about
most of these types of conspiracy
theories is that they are either
unfalsifiable or unlikely to ever be
proven or disproven and of course we
already know the difficulty of actually
disproving some of these conspiracy
theories that's a whole other question
and so these exact types of conspiracy
theories are often used by the right to
dupe and to propagandize their viewers
also unfalsifiable conspiracy theories
often are self-reinforcing in the sense
that conspiracy theories are often based
on premises that can't be disproven you
can't prove a negative and what that
means is whether or not the theory is
true the people that follow it have
absolutely no way to verify that if you
go with this one right the the Tucker
one well they this was all in order to
help Donald Trump well there's
absolutely no Communications that
suggest that the pen stuff was to help
uh to hurt Donald Trump rather we found
no Communications no documents there's
absolutely no proof law enforcement
hasn't found anything it's because
they're in on it the very people who did
it covered up the evidence of the fact
that they did it
unfalsifiable unfalsifiable and that
makes itself reinforcing in many ways
they're not stopping folks they're not
stopping and it is dangerous we will
have all of these clips if you're a
masochist and you actually were just
listening today but you want to see what
Tucker and Marge look like while saying
this horrible nonsense you can find the
clips on our YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show or on
our Instagram by searching Instagram for
davidpackman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show of course
continues to be a community supported
program that means you you are part of
the community at least in my book you
are you can sign up at joinpakman.com we
provide uh quite a suite of member
benefits for our paid subscribers
including the daily bonus show in
addition to the Daily podcast commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
every day you get them hours before
everybody else invitations to the
members only town halls and most
recently a new member benefit which is
that you get access to an equivalent of
my soundboard the sound board from which
I play all those exciting Clips we have
made that a member benefit as well join
pacman.com is the place to sign up okay
let's speak to the audience welcome
welcome you can speak to me at
davidpackman.com Discord very easy you
join the waiting Lobby
and you raise your hand and we are going
to start today with oh I don't know how
about Mark from Los Angeles mark from
Los Angeles welcome to the program uh
what is on your mind today I am uh
thrilled to have you with us
oh boy mark from Los Angeles I've
invited you on but you've got to accept
or it is going to go bye-bye
and there is Mark from Los Angeles
losing the opportunity that's really too
bad let's try Jack from Connecticut Jack
from Connecticut what's going on my
friend
all right Jack from Connecticut has
accepted the invitation but has the
wrong audio device selected oh fantastic
welcome Jack now I can hear you okay
fantastic
um you can hear me yes I can all right
well good afternoon David thank you very
much for having me on again I wanted to
bring I wanted to bring up an
interesting topic that's happening in
about uh two days time okay so in two
days time the Republican National
Committee will select um we'll have its
uh leadership election yes and uh for
the first time in about 10 years there
will be more than one candidate those
candidates are uh
incumbent Rana McDaniel Mike Lindell
unfortunately and the former National
Committee woman for California and I
just wanted to know um if you've been
following the story and if you had any
uh thoughts to share well I support
pillow in this race I have absolutely no
stake whatsoever and no involvement in
Republican Party politics but it just
seems to me that Mike pillow being RNC
chair would be the most humiliating
thing to the Republican party so that's
what I'm in favor of now I couldn't tell
you uh Jack because I haven't been
following it whether pillow has any shot
whatsoever like it from what you know
could he end up being RNC chair
um I mean given the fact that we all
know the Deep division that is running
rampant in the Republican party yeah
um I my my personal guess is either
McDaniel or Mike Lindell honestly at
this point because
realistically I don't think the National
Conference will select um a committee
woman from a deep blue State interesting
well we we are going to see I I hope
it's pillow just for the memes and the
lulls and I know that that's a very
inappropriate way to analyze it but it's
like I I hope they destroy themselves
you know
yeah it's honestly something that the
Republican party needs to realize and
wake up to because if they really want
to re reshape themselves if they even
had an image in the first place they
really need to think about things like
they ever would yeah pillow as your RNC
chair is not exactly a signal that
you're sort of can that you're taking
seriously the destruction that Maga has
done to your party
exactly but it was just it was just an
interesting topic that I wanted to bring
up and uh thank you for taking my call
my pleasure Jack from Connecticut we
will watch the election results very
very closely let's go to Thai from Iowa
Ty from Iowa welcome to the program
what's on your mind today
hey David this is my second time calling
in all right well let's make sure it's
not the last okay
all right so um I just wanted to ask um
do you think it's kind of weird that um
that um so many people kind of list list
countries like China or North Korea as
Communists when they really don't fit
the
the uh what's what is it like the the
definition they would have to be a yeah
the definition they would have to be
like you know a country with no class
money or state you know all that stuff
yeah I mean I don't know that I agree
with you completely in the sense that
um communist and socialist uh countries
it's it's not uncommon that it's sort of
like communistic or socialistic for most
people but then through corruption and
cronyism there actually is an upper
class that that I don't think that alone
makes it not actually communist or
socialist but you you know for me it's
less about is North Korea actually
communist then
um focusing in on the specific human
rights abuses and and just completely
insane familial passing of power that
exists and yeah I don't concern myself
much with whether they really meet this
or that it's sort of like when you do
the Jordan Peterson stuff where you try
to criticize something that Jordan
Peterson said and someone will come out
and say no you're not completely
accurately criticizing what he really
said you're criticizing something else
it's sort of like well you shouldn't
really criticize this as a communist
country because here's a way in which
it's not really communist I don't know I
don't get too involved in that really
yeah I understand that I think people
should just realized that I mean there
are people on the left that can be bad
and people on the right that can be bad
you know and I just uh but I don't know
I just kind of if you really kind of
look into it some people have argued
that North Korea would actually be
influenced by like Japanese fascism
instead of something like I don't know
like
like modern communism yeah listen I I
it's it's mostly moot because I think
for me it's let's identify the things
that are not going well and let's see if
we can improve on them for the benefit
of the people and there are many of
those things in North Korea that's for
sure
yeah that makes sense all right Ty from
Iowa thank you for the call
all right thank you for talking to you
again
uh okay let's go to topi from the Czech
Republic topi from the Czech Republic
welcome to the program
Hello nice to speak to you David uh I am
currently a student from India studying
in Czech Republic okay and I have a
question uh Regarding why don't all the
blue States in uh the US uh sort of come
come together and launch their own
version of uh socialized Healthcare yeah
there's a couple of issues right now I
like the idea I think it's more likely
that the right way to launch some kind
of socialized Health Care system is
going to be within one state right now
the difficulty with doing it in multiple
States is that in the United States
Health Care is state by state you it's
not as the term that's often used topi
is Healthcare isn't sold across state
lines if you're in New York state you
have to select from companies operating
in New York state and that are offering
plans in New York state if you go to
Florida as I will be doing in a few days
hopefully and if I live in Florida I now
need to choose from the plans made
available in Florida by companies
licensed in Florida so it's difficult to
immediately go across state lines what I
would like to see is one state to do a
socialized Health Care system and then
maybe they can grow it into a Consortium
with neighboring states over time but
where I'm 100 with you is states can
start doing this and there was a failed
attempt to get it going in Vermont which
has its own kind of backstory I would
love to see this happen
no I mean like the way they did in the
EU uh State Insurance from one country
is recognized across the EU yes
absolutely I would love to see that it
requires a bunch of regulatory and other
changes but I'm with you I would love to
see it
uh and quickly a second question sure if
it does
um you uh you have been transferred that
you invest in Amazon
but
wouldn't you like push for something
more sustainable like instead of us uh
progressives putting money in companies
that we don't really align with
oh yeah I mean listen it's so first of
all in terms of my individual stocks
I've divested myself from just about
every individual stock I had so you know
I previously invested in alphabet and
Live Nation and Tesla and Amazon and you
know all the I've mostly sold almost all
my individual stocks but the truth is
like even through index funds I am
invested in little pieces of companies
that I don't directly you know that I
don't support whose business models I
don't support and that's an unfortunate
reality you know Noam Chomsky was asked
about this as well and someone
confronted him and said you know you
criticize a lot of these fossil fuel
companies but you're invested in index
funds and so you own a little bit of
them and Chomsky was kind of just
flippantly like well what should I keep
my money under my mattress instead or
something like that I think you bring up
a totally fair point but
um it it there are limits to what people
can do and not every action everyone
take is ever going to be 100 percent
aligned with every moral principle and
you know the the simplest thing for me
to be able to do the best show I can
and to focus on the show is I keep my
investments in really low-cost index
funds where I own the entire total stock
market index and there will be some
companies in there I don't like but I'm
gonna do more good by by leaving the
money there and then
um uh uh simply focusing on the show
does that make sense in any way
yeah uh no I mean uh last semester I
took some courses and this University in
Germany was incredibly left-wing and the
way they do is they try and push their
students to introduce students to
companies that are more sustainable
overall so instead of investing in
mainstream companies you invest there
like in the US you have gravity payments
the CEO was incredible incredibly
popular because he uh reduced his salary
and is pretty much the same as his uh
co-workers so investing in companies
like that
that is that is perfectly fair that is
absolutely fair and I think that's
completely reasonable what you're saying
I I am you know guilty as charged
okay all right my friend topi thank you
very much I I appreciate it
um let's go next to Mike from
Massachusetts Mike from Massachusetts
uh welcome to the program what's on your
mind
Mike from Massachusetts you've got to
accept my invitation to join the
discussion
oh sorry I didn't know about the except
part how you doing David hey I'm doing
well thank you
um I don't have so much of a question
but just kind of like an observation and
what your thoughts might be on it
um I apologize if I sound kind of easily
getting over uh getting over cold but no
problem
um
so I actually watched recently while I
was you know had some down time on the
couch getting over this cold I watched a
docu-series on Netflix uh called World
War II in color okay it's pretty
interesting
and there was an episode dedicated at
least partly to
the rise of the uh anti-anti-semitic
policies in Germany and like how that
just how that just kind of
how that came to be because a lot of
times people ask themselves you know how
did the German people not see this
coming yeah
um and what they just what they
described is I know people get tired of
the comparison but I mean it is
strikingly similar to narratives and
things being said not just about Jews
but other minorities in this country
today uh by the right and you know I
mean a lot of a lot of the a lot of the
argument as to why the German people
never did anything is because a lot of
them just assumed things would never go
that far quote unquote you know uh they
would never actually legalize
persecution and whatnot and I just I'm
curious like how you think how you think
the two situations compared from today
in America to them to them in the 30s
you know this is so tough because
anytime you delve into this
it's very hard to avoid either being not
concerned enough or sounding hyperbolic
and and alarmist right so it's very very
difficult so I'm going to try to like
speak as precisely as possible
I don't think that circumstances for
Jews in the U.S today
are anything like circumstances for Jews
in pre-World War II Germany I think the
starting points are very different
I also think that we are seeing a growth
of a rhetoric about Jews in the U.S and
that that rhetoric is more acceptable
than it's been for a long time as we can
see sort of like in the reactions to
stuff Kanye said were people going
listen Kanye's just kind of telling the
truth or whatever the case may be that
scares me because it's the type of
acceptance or or at least disregard for
the concern that was present in
pre-World War II Germany so like I I I'm
I'm not equivocating but I'm just sort
of saying like the circumstances are
different but a lot of the flippant
attitude does seem similar and I do
think we need to be very concerned about
that
right and it's based on what the
documentary like talked about it was
like that those attitudes people thought
like we can have these attitudes like
it's fine but it's never going to become
policy until it did become policy
um absolutely it's just kind of
interesting that people kind of
feel like they could see these things
coming but really it's easier for it to
slip by than people like to think yep I
completely agree with you I completely
agree and the and the trick is
if you go to alarmist people dismiss you
so what we need to do is find a way to
communicate the alarm in a way that's
accurate but that doesn't get people to
to just tune it out
right I mean and it's interesting like
something else and this would be my last
point I'll let you move on but it's
interesting like something else I
learned from the documentary was like
you know The Narrative of World War II
is obviously you know America and
Britain and a few other allies fighting
a courageous war against just pure evil
like good Evil all the all that all that
stuff but something interesting I
learned is that the Allies actually
acquired a ton of evidence against tons
of Nazi officers who participated in
the Holocaust in Exterminating the
Jewish population as best they could
yeah and interestingly enough there was
actually well the American population
was outraged by it there was actually a
pretty large anti-semitic voice in the
U.S government that pressured the rest
of the Allies to drop charges against
these people uh in exchange for American
Financial Aid following the war yes so
it's just interesting that there are
things that that's a significant piece
of information I did not know until the
other night and that's just like one of
these things that
I feel like is important for Americans
to learn but the right would never want
anyone to learn about that without a
doubt without a doubt Mike I appreciate
the call okay
all right have a good one all right
there's Mike from Massachusetts let's go
next to Dan from Oregon Dan from Oregon
welcome to the program uh what's on your
mind today
and Dan you've got to accept my
invitation to join me here on the show
all right well looks like we've got no
Dan let's go uh instead to Brian from
Ireland Brian from Ireland welcome to
the program
hey David how are you I'm doing well
um just before my question I just wanted
to tell you about a kind of a new
initiative I've launched it's basically
an award
um and it's called the the best way to
make money but when everyone else makes
money to fund themselves it's bad right
I think the bonus show probably is
deserving of this award well you know
I've got good news for you yeah I'm
officially presenting it to you thank
you I I couldn't and from such a country
as allied with us as Ireland I couldn't
be more glad
very strong uh Ally indeed thank you I
just wanted to um
I'm sorry it is something you've dealt
with already in in a previous show but I
haven't heard so much um the fact that
the
house and the Senate are now divided you
know Republicans of the house and
Democrats of the Senate
um and as you said before
Republicans are basically just going to
be obstructionists and not allow
anything to get done for the next couple
of years yeah do you think like based on
both your own opinion and based on
um historical evidence will that be will
that be good for the Republicans uh
electoral chances going forward or will
it be damaging is there is there data on
this
I don't know that I've seen data
um and I don't know that I necessarily
have an answer I mean what what's your
thought
well I mean
I like to think it will be bad I like to
think that people would reward
um you know productive governance and
getting things done for the good of the
people but it just doesn't always happen
you know and particularly you know the
other thing is Republicans have
Republicans have really done something
clever which is they've trained many of
their followers to reward exactly the
opposite of what you and I would reward
like when they train their followers
that hey you know actually government
not doing stuff is good they then can
get rewarded for obstruction right they
they say you know we we have done a
really good job by keeping government
small and not doing anything and not
letting Democrats do anything they have
cultivated a followers a group of
followers that would agree with that and
so it's very hard to make these
assessments of what would be seen as
good or bad by Republican voters
that's true yeah and often those people
that you're talking about that have been
convinced to vote this way you know it's
not in their interest at all it's such a
in such a shame it really is and
unfortunately Democrats have not done a
great job yet of figuring out their way
around this
yeah 100 yeah no thanks for the answer
my pleasure there is Brian from Ireland
great to hear from you we are taking a
very quick break we're still taking
calls so there's no need to hang up uh
very quick break and back right after
this
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's hear
from a few more people taking calls
today via Discord at davidpackman.com
Discord let's hear next from how about
Rick from Southeast Texas Rick from
Southeast Texas welcome to the program
what is on your mind today
hey David welcome thank you so much for
having me thank you so hey my question
is regarding um well of course uh you
know the current state of U.S politics
what else what else could I talk about
um so my question is you know with
George Santos
um I wrote a little uh something in my
notes
um but it's a little outdated now I
thought that he was going to resign but
of course he doesn't have a spine so
that doesn't work out and so
do you think that there is a possibility
with the slim majority that
you know whether it be through
unintended uh deaths or or resignations
do you think that the Democrats could
retake the house by just that
well I don't know about this so so I
mean we've got the Santos resignation
that is maybe going to happen I don't
know it seems like pressure is sort of
starting to to loosen on Santos a little
bit but I don't know the the math of the
other stuff we're you're saying there
could be way more unintended deaths
among Republican members of the House
than Democrats and maybe that could
shift the balance back to Democrats
because remember with a lot of those if
someone dies in office I don't remember
is it the governors that get to a point
a temporary replacement in which case
Red State Governors would just appoint
Republicans again I just don't know that
that makes sense I'm not sure I'm
understanding how it would work
yeah I guess I've wanted to relate it
kind of what you've been talking about
prior episodes where you know obviously
Republicans are less prone to get
vaccines although we know congressmen
Congress people are probably smart
enough to lie to people that get the
vaccine behind their backs which you
know
we know it's going we know what's going
on and so I was thinking maybe that
could play a factor I was just thinking
you know you're more educated than a
Stern graduate
and so I just went so I just wanted to
you know that's all I wanted to say I
just wanted to make sure that you know
um I was just kind of thinking about
that and I don't know I I that's what I
listening I think the issue with all of
these things is that they often become a
replacement for just figuring out how to
win elections and to that extent it they
are a distraction you know if if some
Republicans are going to die and somehow
it'll make Democrats in the majority for
some brief period until the next
election you can't do anything about
that unless your suggestion is to go out
and kill Republicans which obviously
you're not doing and neither am I I just
think it's like there's no point in even
really wasting too much time thinking
about it let's focus on winning the next
next election you know absolutely no I
I'm right there with you thank you so
much my pleasure having me David all
right there is Rick from Southeast Texas
great to have you why don't we go
um why don't we go next to Sal from
Malden Massachusetts Sal welcome to the
program
hello David how are you I'm doing well
thank you for asking
hi
um so I was just calling um just to see
if you had any
um or if you knew anything about this
current case
um about an Angie Diaz murder case no um
have you heard have not heard of it
okay
um basically it's just about a woman who
was married uh with a citizen a United
States citizen
um there's a lot of background where
um it looks like they may have done it
due to
um immigration purposes so
relating this to just immigration policy
um I find it that there's a lot of
issues going on with immigration that
sent that seems to stem from the United
States intervention
um do you think that the United States
um or
um
if this should be proposed
um to give those coming from Central
America affected by
U.S policy basically providing amnesty
for people affected from uh United
States intervention
you're saying the U.S
take some action that for example
affects people in Guatemala as a result
the U.S Bears a responsibility and
should then offer amnesty to Guatemalans
who are in the U.S illegally
yes and are and is it be to all
Guatemalans in the U.S illegally or only
Guatemalans in the U.S illegally as a
direct result of the American
intervention in Guatemala
uh the second the second thing I mean
listen I don't know how you actually do
something like that
um the the truth is so the U.S already
has a process for Asylum seeking based
on the circumstances in one's home
country and those requests are you know
adjudicated through a process it sounds
like what you're saying is
if the reason for the Asylum can be
shown to be a direct result of American
policy
then a sort of priority is given and
like they are definitely granted Asylum
I mean I think it's interesting I think
it's completely impractical and unlikely
to happen but I do think that morally
it's a very interesting issue that you
bring up
uh yeah
um I tend to lean more on the
um blind amnesty just because I've read
a lot about uh Latin America but
um that's a definitely interesting take
David
um and I just had a second quick
question more on the production of the
David Pacman show sure is that okay yeah
um so
just random uh the music that you used
to have in between segments yeah
um have you ever thought of bringing
that back you know not really and mostly
the reason is that music generally
causes copyright issues we also needed
more time that was when we needed to
fill time for Affiliates for a
particular reason the kind of right now
what we've done over time is instead of
having 40 minutes of content per hour we
now have 55 minutes of content per hour
and part of that is that we got rid of
that music so it would only come back in
in lieu of content and I don't think
most people want that
oh okay yeah but some people would
rather 12 minutes of Music instead of me
talking by all means let me know you
know so
maybe you should really say uh David
Pacman album maybe so maybe so all right
so good to hear from you
thank you all right there we go let's go
next to David from Philadelphia David
from Philadelphia welcome sir what is on
your mind today
how you doing David I'm a long time
listener thank you great to hear from
you I think I think you're better than
um better than pretty much every other
podcaster I think The Young Turks uh
they're on a pedestal too much you're
very pragmatic which is why I listen to
you I appreciate uh all compliments
okay so something I want to bring up
because it does strike it's a little bit
personal I grew up with uh parents who
well a mother and a stepfather who
became Maga but you were talking about
how Jim Brewer would uh put on that
crappy comedy routine and everybody's
laughing hysterically just because he's
making uh jokes at the expense who they
don't like
I don't think they really find it funny
oh really so let me just make sure
before you give me your commentary what
David's referring to is we've played
these clips from the reawaken America
Tour it's like a right-wing religious
anti-vax it's almost like a Revival type
thing they do it in its circus tent
sometimes or a church tent and Jim
Brewer does these routines where he
jokes he like walks around what he
pretends to be like a parakeet or
something I don't know and he makes
stupid faces and in the most recent one
he fell down on the ground kind of
mocking Demar Hamlin and the idea that
Demar Hamlin actually suffered a cardiac
arrest from the covet vaccine and one of
the things I commented on as David is
pointing out is people in the audience
are laughing hysterically like they've
never seen you know a comedy movie like
somehow this is funny to them they must
be incredibly sheltered you're saying
David they don't really find it funny
they're pretending
I think they are trying to laugh at it
they're forcing the laughter out of
themselves and I'll explain why this is
why I brought up my parents I'll try to
keep make this anecdote as short as
possible okay
um me and my mom back when we were
closer we watched this TV show called
Supernatural okay the two brothers who
go uh you know travel across the country
killing demons and ghosts and all this
stuff
um well one of the main characters he
had to you know con a bunch of demons or
lie to him or something and the other
main character is like well why are you
gonna lie to him and then the the main
character says well that's how you
become president and this was during
Obama when Obama was President so this
gets a laugh out of my mother yep
um just because she thinks it's making
fun of Obama right then the next week
this same main character he gets
transported into a future where
everything is apocalyptic and then you
see on the newspapers president Sarah
Palin
my mother is completely silent and
there's other anecdotes like this but um
this is the one that sticks out in my
head the most they don't
really think the stuff's funny they just
want to they want to laugh they want
they see themselves as being team
players by laughing at the stuff that
for political reasons they think they're
supposed to be laughing at correct
gotcha it's a perfectly plausible
hypothesis yeah but I that's I've
noticed you've had two videos about Jim
Brewer uh doing that stupid uh bad
comedy as well as Gutfeld and you're
saying like this is what this is what
these right Wingers find funny you know
you're actually making me think I
actually wouldn't be surprised if to
some degree a lot of these right Wingers
don't actually understand comedy and
satire at all whether it's left or right
wing and they're really just taking
social cues where they are aware that
Brewer's a comedian and they are sort of
like in the idea this is supposed to be
funny but they they would they don't get
his comedy and they wouldn't get Chris
Rock's comedy either they just don't get
comedy and they're just laughing based
on the social expectations that they
identify no I think yeah there's that
actually reminds me of when what you
were showing me from Brewer
um it's like you hear the obnoxious
voices he's making and you're you know
that this is supposed to be the funny
part right they know that his obnoxious
voices they're supposed to laugh at that
yeah they laugh even harder because it's
um you know it's they know that that's
what's sometimes you know when you're
supposed to clap and so you can know
when you're supposed to laugh too
yes exactly interesting I think I think
there's a lot to what you're saying
quite frankly
thank you thank you all right David from
Philadelphia thank you very much for the
call I appreciate it let's go to Logan
from Seattle Logan welcome to the
program
Logan welcome to the program Logan from
Seattle
and last chance for Logan from Seattle
welcome to the program
no Logan that is really too bad and that
was going to have to be a short call
anyway because I'm at the end of our
time for today we will take calls again
I appreciate everybody that I was able
to speak to today we'll take a quick
break and continue with the Friday show
right after this
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
all right it is mailbag time well into
the depths of the mailbag as you can
imagine now uh towards the uh end of
January you can email info
davidpackman.com if you would like you
can also sometimes be featured in the
mailbag based on uh YouTube comments
Facebook messages tweets
not typically Tick Tock uh posts or
responses but maybe someday in any case
let's just jump right in because there
is so much meaty substance this week
Jeremy wrote in to me about critical
race Theory and Jeremy says David I've
been listening to your show for a while
now and you are so triggered about
critical race Theory you were in a
meltdown talking about Arkansas Banning
CRT in their schools honestly why are
you so upset about this if they
supposedly don't teach it in the first
place it seems like you support CRT in
schools I seriously want to know if you
do listen
um I am not melting down about what's
happening in Arkansas
I'm worried that a disastrous state is
just wasting money time and resources on
things that won't help them improve
education Arkansas is a disaster on
education I gave you all of the
statistics in my segment last week about
Sarah Huckabee Sanders Banning critical
race Theory what upsets me about it is
that the people of Arkansas
voted for someone who was clearly being
selected to do this type of nonsense
virtue signaling rather than fixing the
economy or getting jobs there or dealing
with the horrible educational numbers or
any of it she bans something that just
isn't happening and she claims to be a
small government conservative so I have
no plans to live in Arkansas I feel bad
for the people that that do in the sense
that it's not even just that culturally
I couldn't take it they have had a
string of leaders that just waste their
taxpayer money of which they don't
really have that much quite frankly
Arkansas very much depending on the
federal Dole
and do things that are just a waste of
time and money so it's not that I'm
melting down it's that it's a terrible
thing for the people of Arkansas and I
feel bad for them I feel very very bad
for them
um Trump uh D.L wrote in about Trump and
says why are you so obsessed with Trump
get over it you never talk about the
Biden crime family they have been
corrupt for over 40 years maybe because
of your age you didn't know this
but you could educate yourself now looks
like the Dems want him out he's a fool
even Obama mentioned it on tape Obama I
don't know what DL is talking about I
have no idea what he's talking about and
remember Biden crime family
investigate Biden for the classified
document stuff if there was wrongdoing
do whatever you need to do
but keep investigating Trump as well
because the situations are very
different Hunter Biden Hunter Biden did
something criminal or potentially
criminal law enforcement and the justice
department should investigate charge the
guy if he's guilty throw him in jail I
don't care
but for Republicans to make Hunter Biden
the foremost political issue is
disgusting Hunter Biden has nothing to
do with the Biden Administration unlike
Ivanka and Jared and so on
um and to take up Congressional time as
they plan to do
investigating Hunter give me a break
it's pathetic so I don't know what DL is
talking about but DL seems very very
triggered Justin wrote In
Justin says I treat your show like the
news because I'm not particularly fond
of TV news though I do watch other TV
commentary like Chris Hayes that Lauren
Skye Ari and others from MSNBC I
actually listen to all of them through
clips on YouTube you should have a
segment on your show where you cover
multiple recent headlining National and
international stories five to seven
offer quick commentary and move on to
the next thing you'd pick up people
looking for quick news you know we tried
this and nobody watched it there's this
interesting thing that happens and I
don't know if it's a blessing or a curse
I really don't Justin but sometimes when
you do your show a certain way for a
while
and you build an audience based on that
it's easy to think hey you know if I did
this other thing that other people have
success with I would just double My
Success I would do so so so well but
oftentimes when you test those things it
doesn't happen and I don't know the
reason why maybe it's because I've been
pigeonholed into doing the type of show
I do maybe it's because I wouldn't be
good at doing a five to seven story News
segment back for whatever reason when we
tried it nobody watched it I am always
interested in trying new formats and
ideas but that particular one didn't
work when we tried it in the past Dave
wrote in and says I enjoy watching your
YouTube posts that said it is quite
distracting when you're playing back
things and pause to make comments I'd
rather hear more of the video and then
hear your take on it so listen this has
been a disagreement among some of my
audio audience for a long time
I have taken the position based on what
I do
and the emails that I've received that
most people are watching this listening
to this
to hear my commentary now you could say
well fine but keep your commentary for
after the clip when I did that we tested
doing that I got a ton of emails from
people saying David hey you know I get
that news stations will often just play
a clip in its entirety and then like say
something later but the reason I'm
watching you is actually for you to
pause and break down break it down piece
by piece so David this is just a
preference and with peace and love I
appreciate that you don't like it every
time we've adjudicated this every time
we've investigated this the the
consensus is the majority not everybody
but the majority is David keep doing it
the way you do it when you want to pause
and tell us something about the clip let
us know Zachary wrote in now this one
this is tongue-in-cheek okay Zachary
says David I've been listening to your
show for years and the last few weeks
you've been talking about George Santos
and his supposed lies to think somebody
would spread such horrible claims about
the first man on the moon is sickening
not only that he is the president of the
United United States the king of England
and the world's tallest man
so have some respect you should be
ashamed of yourself David do better the
the king of England thing is funny I
once interviewed a guy named David
windmiller who since passed away may he
rest in peace
um and he David when Miller was known I
believe he did anyway if he's still
alive then I apologize David when Miller
was known for t quote teaching people to
stuff their names full of punctuation
marks like semicolons and dashes and
stuff which he said would make you
non-taxable it didn't work people would
get thrown in jail for contempt when
they tried it but he claimed that he was
the king of Hawaii
um it was it was quite a ride I have to
tell you
uh but in any case
George Santos yes a very very honest man
Jeff wrote in and says good morning I
find it hypocritical that the people
questioning vaccines due to some
athletes having health issues are so
fast to dismiss why we are seeing once
in a generation weather events that seem
to be occurring monthly I'd like to hear
your thoughts thanks for the great
content
so let's here's the deal
this is a very common thing in politics
left and right do it but right now it's
being weaponized much more by the right
if you find an anomaly
and you want to use it to claim that it
is the status quo
you do it
and if you find an anomaly
and it is useful for it to be merely an
anomaly
then you say it's just an anecdote it's
just an anomaly and so although climate
science tells us that we should expect
exactly what we've been seeing extreme
high temperatures extreme low
temperatures weather events being more
serious more frequent hurricanes being
all these different things
that's not the story that works so they
say this is just whether it's not
climate forget about it whatever
on the other hand when it comes to
uh an expected number of young people
dying remember we went through the
numbers there has not actually been an
increase
they want to tell the story that it's an
epidemic because of the vaccine they
just do it uh the facts and the science
simply do not matter Andrew wrote In and
says Marjorie Taylor green on the
homeland security committee with
Marjorie Taylor green on this committee
asks Andrew should I as a Jew be
concerned about the investigation of our
space lasers listen Andrew
if they want to come and take the space
lasers that's one thing
but if Marjorie Taylor green comes from
my chocolate babka she will take it from
my cold dead hands that I guarantee you
sir
Michelle wrote in about trolls
speaking of which more comments tonight
from listeners who scorn you David I
find it astounding and sad that there
are so many people who have nothing
better to do than listen to podcasters
they dislike personally I struggle to
find time to keep up with the podcasters
and news sources that I like I can't
imagine wasting time following anyone I
disliked I guess some people just aren't
happy unless they're hating someone
hating on someone so sad yet this is a
really good point
I don't have the time to watch the shows
I want to watch to keep up with the
podcasts I like I don't have time for it
to read the books I want to read the
idea that I would waste any time with
the stuff I don't like is uh is
laughable but again these people have no
lives Michelle that's what you have to
remember info davidpackman.com if you
have something to say to me
say it to my face and I mean that by
email info davidpackman.com we have such
a great week of programs coming up for
you next week but we have the bonus show
first oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad thank
your lucky stars every day you're not
Dave Pacman well many in our audience do
Alex you can sign up at joinpakman.com
let's make it a thing we'll see you then
foreign